aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée pour plus
de 12 millions d'élèves et au moins un
million de salariés de l'éducation
nationale après deux semaines de
vacances rythmée par les réunions
familiales l'apparition de nouveau
variant du virus et un hiver froid qui
facilite la circulation du virus alors
que de nombreux pays européens ont
décidé de reconfirmer ou même de
reporter la rentrée de plusieurs jours
en france les autorités ont jugé bon de
maintenir le retour en classe
une situation qui inquiète parents
d'élèves et scientifique
dans un communiqué le collectif école et
famille oublier alerte les autorités sur
les risques liés à cette situation
chaque jour compte et correspond à des
contaminations supplémentaires laisser
l'épidémie à l'école c'est exposer la
société tout entière et il faudra
malheureusement payer collectivement le
prix de cet attentisme qui déjà en mars
nous avait conduits à regarder
tranquillement la lombardie sans réagir
allons-nous persévérer dans notre
stratégie de l'échec
li d'action et l'impréparation sont
elles une méthode de leur côté les
enseignants déplorent qu'aucun
renforcement du protocole sanitaire
n'ait été mis en place pour assurer la
protection du personnel et des élèves
la troisième vague et là elle arrive en
fait c'est bien la pologne même le
prolongement de la deuxième vague
puisque rien n'a été fait de sérieux en
france on est le seul pays quasiment en
europe a continué à avoir les écoles
ouvertes à 35 40 par classe sans aucune
distanciation social ça je veux vraiment
que les gens l'entendent
il n'y a aucune distanciation sociale à
l'école les enseignants les personnels
d'éducation les ash et autres sont en
danger
ils peuvent attraper le co est vide à
cause du travail rien n'est fait il n'y
a aucun protocole sérieux et solide
l'école le collège le lycée de france
sur les endroits les moins sécurisée
possible des inquiétudes conforté par de
récentes études qui ne présage rien de
bon selon le rapport comme corps dans
l'institut pasteur le risque de
contagion est plus élevé pour un enfant
en crèche en maternelle voir au collège
et même au lycée alors que les souches
mutantes du pot midi
neuf apparu au royaume uni sont plus
contagieuses les hôpitaux britanniques
constate une nette augmentation est d
admission de jeunes enfants
pour certains scientifiques la rentrée
en france aurait dû être mieux préparée
il faudrait reporter la rentrée scolaire
d'au moins une semaine
ça permettrait de réduire la circulation
virale après les fêtes
préparez les écoles et observer la
situation au royaume uni en france c'est
un peu tard pour l'organisation mais on
ne va pas y échapper par la suite avec
l'aggravation de la situation au
royaume-uni en irlande ne commettons pas
la même erreur que lors de l'arrivée de
la première vague en italie pas de
procrastination en europe ne résoudront
pas les écoles début janvier mais
vaccinons vaccinons vaccinons d'abord
accélérons la vaccination et ses
appréhensions et bien une contraste avec
les propos de jean michel blanquer le
ministre de l'éducation nationale en
milieu scolaire on réussissait à moins
se contaminer qu'en dehors du milieu
scolaire mon ans je sais qu'en 2020 2021
on est une année scolaire normal et je
ferai tout pour cela
jérôme salomon directeur de la santé
fait part de ses réserves
nous sommes très vigilants pour éviter
que ça ne se diffuse pas comme au
royaume uni ces variantes ne sont pas
forcément plus dangereuse mais elles
sont nettement plus contagieuse elle
toucherait aussi davantage les jeunes il
faut donc qu'on soit très attentifs au
milieu scolaire et universitaire les
enfants reviennent de différents
endroits en france ou à l'étranger
ça peut rabattre les cartes de la
situation épidémiologique
alors que la menace d'une troisième
vague de kobe 19 plane sur la france le
corps médical insiste il faut rester
mobilisé l'impact des fêtes de fin
d'année sur la situation sanitaire ne
sera visible que dans plusieurs semaines